the Turkish president arrived in the
coastal city of Sochi with high
expectations
he came with a mission to convince
Vladimir Putin to renew the U.N brokered
Black Sea grain initiative that the
Russian president withdrew from in July
following a three-hour meeting little
progress was achieved
the West deceived Russia about the
humanitarian nature of the grain deal we
do not tolerate it anymore
despite his strong words his Turkish
opposite maintained his optimism
we believe that we will hopefully reach
a solution that will meet expectations
in a short time
half of Ukraine's grain exports crossed
the Black Sea to Nations around the
world but after July's attack on the
cursed Bridge linking Russia and Crimea
they stopped
President Putin says the agreement in
Rich Western businesses and promises
made to exempt Russia exports from
sanctions have been broken
President Putin insists that Russia is
ready to return to this deal as long as
the agreement is upheld in its entirety
that means the reconnection of Russia's
agricultural Bank to the Swift
International banking system that was
cut off by the EU last June as a result
of Russia's so-called special military
operation in Ukraine
now Alternatives need to be explored to
make this deal work
this will be correct if for Russia and
Turkey together maybe with Qatar will
agree on some independent Financial
scheme to realize this deal because uh
traditional payments were the Western
banks will not be possible during this
battle bill
turkey is the only NATO member country
that still has a relationship with
Russia following the war in Ukraine a
relationship that continues to be
important for both sides but much of the
world will have to deal with the reality
that the U.N brokered Black Sea
initiative could be a deal of the past
and prepare for the consequences
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera